hello star wars fans hello there for all
your incredible support and response to
obi-wan kenobi you got it ewan
i love dab and luke news our premiere
date is moving just a couple of days
from wednesday to friday
okay here's the exciting part the first
two episodes will primarily first do
here's the exciting part
we're going straight up against stranger
things we hate them all
dusting on disney
[Music]
play all 17 episodes drop them all we
don't want to wait i don't want to wait
[ __ ] wednesday
hello there welcome back to new
rockstars the premiere date of obi-wan
kenobi has just moved to may 27th when
we will get the first two episodes which
means if the rumors are true that
episode three through six of the series
will be darth vader season that would
mean as soon as june 1st folks darth
vader will be back in our lives but what
is hayden christensen now saying about
this return and what will it look like
when he locks sabers with
this is wookie leaks it's our weekly
reaction to the latest and greatest star
wars i'm here with tommy bechtold oh
kenobi's about to be twice as nice baby
boy i can't wait give me two episodes
give me three episodes give me four you
think i'm scared cancel all my plans i'm
gonna have to break a bunch of girls
hearts because friday night tommy b is
unavailable it's like we're back with
the mandalorian when they used to drop
those on fridays
getting our weekend started early with
star wars right
this is exciting we learned the premiere
date it's moving to friday may 27th
we're gonna get the first two episodes
but the following week episode drops
will return to wednesdays
so episode 3 is gonna be on june 1st
episode 4 june 8th episode 5 june 15th
episode 6 the finale june 22nd movie
once now competing directly with
stranger things season 4 part 1 also
dropping but on netflix may 27th so this
really sets up the month of june
starting june 1st to be the month of
vader but is he gonna win or is he gonna
lose this rematch with obi-wan obviously
they're both gonna survive it's gonna be
some kind of draw
but who's going to have the the victory
who's going to have the high ground
coming out of this season with what we
talked about today but before we talk
about that we want you to skidaddle on
over to newrockstarsmerch.com
and grab one of those new moon night
shirts the new latest obsession tomb of
the moon god limited edition they're
already starting to run out of these you
got to get your hands on them it's a
collectible shirt inspired by the hit
disney plus show so grab one before they
sell out and then when you do that
you'll get the added option to write in
a custom shout out that will be
displayed during our weekly inside
marvel after shows
exciting so find that shirt and other
great merch over at
newrockstarsmerch.com
all right tommy this week in star wars
what are we talking about well eric i
think it's the question that's on all of
our minds and it's a question that i
have quite frankly personally stayed up
late at night pondering uh as long as i
also along with my life choices the
question is will vader win or lose in
his rematch with kenobi
yeah that's that's what i'm wondering
coming out of this going into this show
and probably coming out of this show
who's gonna win this uh is it who's
gonna be uh who's gonna have the bigger
chip on their shoulder
when they face each other again on the
death star a new hope well hayden
christensen was actually talking about
this to entertainment weekly this week
they asked how it felt to be back in the
vader suit and he said well without
getting into too much detail it was
amazing it's a great honor to get to put
that suit on it was mostly a lot of
excitement because i had spent enough
time with this character and it felt
like i knew him and coming back to it
felt very natural in a lot of ways and i
was just really excited to come in and
play darth vader at this point in the
timeline because it did feel like a
natural continuation of your journey
with the character
now
you may have also heard some uh possible
footage of vader and obi-wan dueling
that uh that might have been making the
rounds this week we're not going to show
it here even though this show is called
wookie leaks uh we're just not going to
show it you can go find it yourself if
you're so inclined but basically
i don't think it's it's really spoiling
anything that's gonna happen it's just a
couple seconds of these two lock and
lightsabers interesting though on a
sandy planet we don't know what planet
uh and then vader powerfully force
pushes obi-wan back blasting him
directly out of frame
uh like super smash bros style but it's
not that goofy wire work where he's like
whoa
like an arc that you usually see bts
footage for movies no no this [ __ ] looks
good it's like
exit stay dry like cane wow hook some
out of frame it's pretty wild
man take them away
now obviously we know both of these men
are going to survive this duel it's
going to end in some kind of draw
but if we consider obi-wan to have won
the first duel on mustafar after he had
the high ground and vader obviously to
have won the final duel though you know
obviously a debatable point but
ob wants corporeal life effectively
ended at that point
who is going to win the duel on this
series uh is it going to be a darth
vader victory to where obi-wan limps
away from this fight and really loses
something is it gonna be vader again
letting the old man get the best of them
as we the audience are gonna be the jury
who are we most likely to assign the win
to when all the points are tallied i got
to be honest with you eric i think that
this is going to be another kenobi
win
i just think that the
the kind of i hesitate to say the
confidence that sir alec guinness
obi-wan kenobi versus vader in a new
hope
it was not the man that had last been
like frightened by vader you know what i
mean it was not it was not that was not
the that was not the way like he still
seemed like he was very much in control
in the dynamic of their relationship one
thing i would love to see this is just
such a very specific detail is i would
love for vader to get the high ground on
kenobi at some point and then for him to
reveal that he didn't teach anakin every
single trick he had in the book because
he could somehow
use the low ground as an advantage
against vader just completely mind
effing him like being like like having
vader maybe be like now i have the high
ground and then kenobi does some crazy
thing that turns the low ground into his
to his advantage i just feel like
there's some more damage to do to
vader's psyche to push him into full
emperor enforcer
dark side
like i just think that this is gonna i
think obi-wan defeating him one last
time is gonna be what just creates a new
hope vader rogue one vader if that makes
sense yeah i agree tommy that's a that's
a good thought there i think you know
it's are we going to
uh consider enough of a victory for
obi-wan kenobi if he just walks away
from this largely unscathed uh because i
wonder if the conflict between these two
is really going to be a proxy fight yeah
they're going to come they're going to
lock blades at some point that's what
we've been promised but like what brings
them back together is there are there
some other acolytes of theirs uh
obviously uh obi-wan is trying to
protect luke uh vader has got this new
inquisitor program that he is uh
responsible for he's got his pride he's
got his reputation his street cred that
if that gets injured in some way he's
gonna feel pretty pissed off uh so like
if when when two characters lives or not
stay not at stake
in some ways the conflict between them
becomes more interesting because then
they're they're fighting over something
different they're fighting over the
well-being and lives of other people of
of the whole galaxy of characters are
trying to protect uh or of their
reputations or of their secrets you know
so it's almost like uh watching a chess
match between two people as they're just
trying to outsmart the other or another
analog perhaps
benny and
in the food
eventually elmer fudd puts that shotgun
in his own mouth and blows sprites out
because that rabbit drives them nuts
where did i get absolutely where did i
go just then
you went to a very dark place and i
liked it
no continue your reaction absolutely i
oh no mine was just going to be more of
a meditation on looney tunes which is
not what this show is about however
you can tune in to talking tunes with
eric and tommy yeah
new episodes will drop wednesday nights
at 3 a.m and they will be immediately
deleted afterwards right catch it right
when it drops yeah it's we try to find
our uh that little window where most of
new rockstars is asleep so yeah you know
we got a couple more hours playing video
games and not worried about it right two
plugged in uh now i want to ask you
tommy do you think obi-wan kenobi as a
series might do some uh controversial
moves and potentially
retcon some things about vader's inner
mindset that
we previously assumed to be something
else so for example do you think the
show could reveal that vader might
actually have known that obi-wan was on
tatooine
and decided to leave him there maybe
because he's like i can't get close to
this guy anymore yeah and i think the
way that you can do that retconning
that's i yeah i i mean i do think the
answer is
possibly i know that's a cop-out answer
in my opinion they should and can't they
can and should
the way you retcon things without it
being a total like you know terminator
whatever that last terminator dark fate
was where they're like the last three
movies just didn't happen right yeah
they're like like this is just a sequel
to the second one the way the way you do
that is you just reveal
an extra layer to the person's like
personality like vader
like had just a tiny acorn of compassion
or pragmaticism in his mind where he was
like
he's not hurting he's no threat to the
empire
on babysitting on tatooine in fact
having one of the most dangerous jedis
in the entire galaxy marooned on a
basically the planet version of a desert
island is probably a best-case scenario
and you know at a certain point if that
boy grows up and i mean although i guess
you wouldn't know luke was the
was his son well yeah that's kind of
that's kind of the
question right like yeah he
i if he has most star wars fans
absolutely not vader cannot learn that
luke skywalker is there on that planet
because otherwise he would have gone
there to destroy him
way sooner
but maybe there's a way that vader can
learn that obi-wan is on tatooine on his
if you think about his home planet
without uh
knowing that what he's there to do to
protect there's an arrogance of vader
like empire strikes back more so we
learned than even in in a new hope
there's a certain like presence of vader
where he i mean he might believe that he
has crushed like the the empire has
crushed obi-wan's desire to even be a
jedi anymore and be active so in his
mind it's almost like when it comes to
the threat that obi-wan kenobi poses
obviously his mind and his skill set are
still a threat but as long as vader i
mean if they can retcon it to the fact
that vader has some kind of surveillance
on him that he knows that he's not gonna
you know make a run for something that
maybe he doesn't feel that he's the most
imminent threat like vader i mean
he's not you know he's not a man drawn
to super emotional things until
you know later on in the original
trilogy and the first like he's kind of
a terminator in the first one and then
the second one gets a little more
complex but like i i just don't i could
see that i could see that being a way
that they can retcon that where he just
knows but also is not threatened by him
yeah yeah agreed i don't think uh i'm
going to view it as any kind of major
betrayal if in this series darth vader
realizes that obi-wan kenobi is on
tattoo and i think it might be a little
weird if vader knows that luke is there
too yes i i wholeheartedly agree with
that i also i'm just thinking that this
exact snippet of this episode
conversation is gonna cue the most
furious youtube comments we ever get
like are you kidding me here's a list of
things obi-wan kenobi can do and it'll
be like turn water into fire
fishes and loaves for a thought like
they'll just start describing jesus
and then i'll just give it a thumbs up
like i always do because i read all your
youtube comments guys and especially the
ones about my body so keep them coming
but you want to know what the magic of
youtube is with these longer episodes
the people who don't uh like know who we
are and are predisposed to hate us are
more likely to just react to the
thumbnail they're not going to stick
around 10 minutes into this
episode and then watch it now what may
happen is one person may see it and then
uh time code it and alert it to other
people on reddit and twitter and say
listen to what or they'll clip it out
and then share it out of context and
then that will be our undoing but all
right even then either way come at me
bro i got two episodes of kenobi in the
pipes and i got two episodes of tom noby
attached to my shoulders bam bam
yeah but i think uh ultimately uh i was
even re-reading that 2015 vader comic
moment where boba fett tells them that
the rebel pilot who destroyed the death
star was named skywalker and then the
way it is drawn and written in that
moment makes it seem like vader is
putting it all together in that moment
where he goes i have a son
but it is going to annoy some people
there is a way to read that where vader
is like reminding himself like he knew
that at one point blocked out that truth
or he's like realizing like oh it was my
son named skywalker who did this you
know like he knew the whole time he just
like
it uh blocked out like you know uh
palpatine's training had kind of forced
that out of his mind
that he wouldn't focus on the master
manipulator yeah
palpatine basically crafted the perfect
soldier for himself like he was like he
he took a a very powerful potential jedi
master and made him into a sith lord
just to kind of wrap up here tommy i i
think ultimately
i think people are going to find that
those kind of logical
if they're
the more serious retcons are gonna bug
some people for sure but you can do
little massaging of the history if it
means we get to see obi-wan and vader
fight again because so much has been
done um
especially in the filoni chapters of the
star wars universe to kind of like
change the meaning of moments in the
name of redeeming certain things from
the prequels uh yeah and clarifying them
uh and giving us these nice grace notes
uh even though like
would it have made sense when we were
watching the prequels if ahsoka tano
never came up once at all like if she
was that important
i guess he could make some arguments
well at that point she was banished from
the jedi order and at that point you
know they just had conversations that
were focused on clone wars events and
things uh involving patterns
you always make a great point that's
just not where the cameras were pointed
that's just not where the cameras were
pointing yeah i just i mean i think that
is the best explainer from like
people getting their their heads just
exploding over like why wasn't that
person there or why wasn't it like i
don't know man it's a movie and it lasts
two and a half hours so they can only
show so much yeah and and just the
chapters of vader's backstory that we
know of from comics from books from uh
lines from inferences we made coming out
of the prequels uh during rogue one and
a new hope uh does not mean that that's
like the only history obviously we know
about the character and there could be
other things that he knew that he just
didn't disclose that he just didn't talk
about or that maybe he just didn't focus
on so i think there are new truths that
can be revealed and i think it is
possible at the end of the day that uh
that vader
stayed the hell away from tatooine
because of some kind of fight that he
had with obi-wan kenobi where kenobi's
like look if you ever try to come here
again not only will you be fighting me
you'll be fighting the force coast of
qui-gon you'll be fighting uh the force
ghost of all the jedi we're all here and
we're not gonna tell you why we're here
but we're here because this is your home
world and we're gonna keep you away from
here just to piss you off and maybe
that's reason enough alone sure like
vader never needs to know that luke is
there he's just like whoa my crazy old
master is on this planet yeah and i
don't want to mess with him again all my
uncles
all my angry uncles are there and aunts
and aunts
and aunts
and aunts
we have uh some numbers we're going to
get into in just a moment but first we
want to thank some people who helped us
make this episode our friends at peloton
thank you peloton for sponsoring this
episode if you've ever started a fitness
routine you know that uh month two or
month three is when it gets a lot
tougher you start getting bored you look
for more excuses not to exercise doing
the same workout over and over can sap
your motivation and hurt your progress
but that's where our friends at peloton
can help with their app you don't need
to own one of the cool peloton bikes to
use this app for workouts at home they
are constantly adding new classes new
music new ways to keep your workouts fun
and motivating peloton has a workout for
every day and every schedule including
bike workouts yoga meditation dance
cardio and more they have boxing classes
that i'm really excited to try they're
great for beginners and you can get your
heart pumping while learning the
fundamentals of the sweet science of
channeling your inner pedageless use the
app on all your devices play it on your
tv to work out in the living room or
bring your phone or your tablet into the
yard for some sun and sweat outdoors if
you want to add some great motivating
variety to your workouts check out the
peloton app by clicking the link in the
video's description or visit one
onepeloton.com to learn more that's
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
but tommy let's get back into uh obi-wan
kenobi here what else are we talking
about this week well we've got another
question eric and this time we're
talking stats you know me i'm a stat guy
runs batted in doubles most
stormtroopers killed most misfired
blasters by a stormtrooper i love all
the records and all the stats but this
is what i want to know let's talk
numbers will obi-wan kenobi be disney
plus
most watched show
ever
it's a valid question to ask because the
hollywood reporter recently released
some numbers that they gathered
according to nielsen on the streaming
figures of disney plus big titles since
the platform launched in late 2019 now
according to this report the most
watched title on disney plus
from the star wars titles to the marvel
titles the beatles get back
was the mandalorian so the mandalorian
season 2 according to them was streamed
for 8.38 billion minutes followed by the
mandalorian season 1 at 5.42 billion
minutes the next highest uh the highest
of all the marvel ones was loki which
streamed for 5.23 billion minutes and
then one division at 4.8 billion minutes
uh now hawkeye for 35 minutes yeah
hawkeye didn't clock eye up there to too
high but uh it's uh but it's it's
fascinating to me to see this but we
should mention some caveats to this data
because each season the mandalorian had
eight episodes and in season two most of
them were over 45 minutes
loki had only six episodes of that
average length one division had nine
episodes but a lot of them were shorter
than a half hour
so they're looking at specifically the
the number of minute streams so
obviously there are titles like uh
hamilton on disney plus or in kanto on
disney plus that have racked up some
huge numbers but each of those that's
like two hours or two and a half hours
of content that's really being streamed
there uh they're really just looking at
the series which uh in total you're
saying there's a miranda effect yes like
the mandela effect the miranda effect is
when you misremember how long a movie
lasts you're like hamilton that was nine
hours long like no the running time was
actually three hours i thought a miranda
effect was where you like overshare the
sexual exploits you had with your three
other friends over brunch yes that's
right you know what
hey everyone's got their own miranda i
mean the miranda effect might actually
be a legal term because you got your
miranda rights like there's like a thing
where the miranda effect has there's the
miranda line in baseball which is uh i
think it's the miranda line which is if
you hit below 200. so like if you you're
below oh that's the mendoza line sorry
guys well there's that trench in the
atlantic ocean the miranda trench where
just a bunch of mirandas get dumped
there and they disappear and then there
were the mirandas twins that uh
murdered their parents after going to a
knicks game
and then i think uh there's our boss uh
phillip miranda
yeah guys tweet adam at philip miranda
anyway he's such a samantha everybody
knows that come on
um but yeah i think it's fascinating
that there is this baby yoda effect for
sure the grogu effect that is uh that is
happening and there's just this like
surprise that hit us here at new
rockstars because our content numbers
for the marvel disney plush shows way
way higher than those for the
mandalorian um but that might just mean
marvel fans are more likely to flock to
youtube for content than star wars fans
that you just have these uh unspoken
poor silent masses who don't spend all
their time on youtube and twitter who
just enjoy content and turn it off and
then go outside it has nothing to do
with the hosting personalities on those
shows i mean everybody knows the star
wars stuff is way more charismatically
presented but the marvel stuff is just
done in a way that i don't know i guess
it's more digestible because the words
are smaller and maybe just simpler
themes and like i don't know i think
it's the after show effect i think i
think you and i just go to off the rails
and it scares uh
that's true yeah real ones know it's all
in the star wars beat yeah
i marvel at the star wars content we put
out here that's the way i d see it
[Laughter]
uh either way i just think this
indicates obi-wan kenobi might break all
these records if there are people who
are just going to plug themselves in for
star wars at the rates that these
nielsen numbers are indicating that
means everyone who watched the
mandalorian if they all watch obi-wan
kenobi plus all the disney plus
subscribers who have recently joined the
platform since the mandalorian season
two and then if you also add in just all
these additional viewers curious to
revisit this era in star wars history
this show could be
massive
by far the biggest title we've seen on
disney parks absolutely i mean tommy
tommy and i were in chicago in february
and then at one point i just kind of did
uh an applause-o-meter survey of that
audience there uh because i'm like super
bowl sunday is coming up we're gonna get
some trailers at that point we thought
we might get an obi-wan trailer then but
i'm like we're gonna get another trailer
for multiverse and madness bringing
another trailer maybe get a first
trailer for obi-wan kenobi which title
are you guys more excited for when i
said uh multiverse madness pretty solid
applause there now they didn't know that
patrick stewart was gonna show up in the
trailer but still you know you would
think that'd be the bigger one when i
said kenobi trailer the crowd erupted on
their feet tommy steve palpatine up in
the uh in the balcony almost jumped off
and crowd surfed over to us to give us a
high five yeah shout out to palpatine
and his son whose name now is escapes me
but what a good kid it was like go yeah
it was so great
that kid was awesome uh yeah and she
was it like gabriel or something like
that i can't remember but they were
great it was awesome to meet them but
i'm just saying like the kenobi
the kenobi stands are out there man and
this is
it's going to break the platform i'll
tell you what kenobi stands
right inside your screen right now okay
i'm a kenobi boy all the way i'm a cano
bro can over us
we're very toxic we do not allow women
in
and we all kiss at every meeting that's
right we agreed and we don't touch our
hands because of covid but we kiss
i just think i want to ask tommy do you
think obi-wan as a series is going to be
catered more to the fair weather star
wars consumers the canoe bros that are
out there or
since they're going to be bringing in
elements like the inquisitors and
adapting them almost perfectly in live
action from what we've seen do you think
this is going to be just another
fellonian world immersion experiment
that rewards the rebels fans the fallen
orders fans the the clone wars fans uh
people have read the comics is it going
to be like a nerd's paradise or is it
going to be something that uh that
reaches out to everyone how are we gonna
look at this show you know you know i
can't help myself because i've been
spending most of my life living in a
nerd's paradise
uh
i
think it's gonna fall towards the ladder
but they're going to use the former get
the old school canoe bros get all the
original trilogy heads in on the kenobi
title in on the ewan mcgregor playing
kenobi and that's when the old bait and
switch comes in and filoni's like here's
all the fun things i did with the
animated series and here's all the
characters from that and from the
extended universe and and uh
let's now merge these two worlds
together it's okay
59 year old man watching this in your in
your like 300 000 house in your leather
recliner with like a
a gold framed photo or of of george
lucas petting r2d2 it's okay that you
have expensive star wars memorabilia all
over your mansion
this show will still be for you obi-wan
kenobi will still be there darth vader
will still be there there are going to
be these people called the inquisitors
and you're safe you're in a safe space
this will be very fun if you get through
the episode go watch high school musical
2 the musical it's for you too go reward
yourself with that i think this is going
to be what i like to call a little bit
of boomer bait you know what we're going
to boomerang get those we're going to
get those boomers on the line and we're
going to reel them in we're going to
reel them right in tommy it sounds like
you're you're talking to a specific
boomer i'm like who is this guy who has
a 300 yeah i just want you to watch
kenobi with me dad we've gotten there
we've got there
i think ultimately the fact that deborah
chao is is doing this the fact that they
rewrote it from the original writer i i
don't know if this is going to feel
exactly like boba fett or
or the mandalorian did i think it's
going to be reaching i think there might
be a couple things that that fans of
rebels and and fans of uh the comics
might feel like that's not how i
pictured it going yeah uh but i think
ultimately it's gonna be a crossover hit
uh so more folks i think it's gonna be
massive i think it's gonna be absolutely
massive yeah uh and i you know it's
interesting they said that andrew
stanton like the pixar director is
co-writing one of the episodes oh wow i
just found very
i
interesting
mr uh finding nemo possible lightning
mcqueen crossover maybe maybe we could
tell them obi-wan come on in everyone i
got you buddy here we go oh no what's
that a lightsaber oh wait lightning
mcqueen is my best friend
obi-wan
you can't tell vader where you live
they're like wait
mobius
morbius
yeah correction there um well i think
this is going to be uh uh one for the
books for sure yes
can't wait to crack open the book of
obi-wan well but that's it for this
episode of wikileaks don't forget to
check out our many great merch options
at newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me at eavos follow tommy at
tommyback don't follow new rockstars
subscribe to wikileaks wherever you get
your podcasts thanks for watching and
goodbye
you